what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel um today's
morning coffee Thoughts with an actual
coffee that I always say I'm gonna quit
but then I go to a new city and I gotta
try the coffee so what am I supposed to
do
um before I start don't forget to
subscribe to the channel and ring that
notification Bell also sign up for my
memberships
um there's four tiers and in one of the
tiers you get a Discord the second tier
and behind the scenes vlogs
um so today
I'm in New York City
and I was flown out to New York City
to do a vice panel on feminism and you
know you know I got opinions
I was the most I swear to God guys I
don't know how they're gonna edit it I
said a lot of things they very well
could take out of context so I pray to
God they don't but they might I just
said let bygones be bygones I'm gonna
say what I want to say
and um it was interesting because the
leftists that they brought on were so
hostile like conservatives we don't
really get angry like that
why is that when whenever I would say
something
they would just get mad it was weird
like it was weird I would I asked them
in 2022
name one thing that is holding women
back in 2022 and then they'd be like
well well
you you're privileged and I'm like yeah
okay okay and and yeah I get it I'm
privileged and and and then they'd be
like well like one girl didn't have legs
and she'd be like well I'm disabled I
don't have legs and I'm like
well what does that have to do with
women like most women have legs I'm
sorry yeah you didn't get the right lot
in life but
that's like a you not a women thing and
then they're like well I'm a refugee
this girl's like I'm just like
okay you came here and you're like four
it's not the same thing as like
okay
um
I'm like okay but women like most women
aren't refugees and then it was so funny
I'm like name one name one thing and
then there's like the pay Gap and I'm
like well women don't want to do the
hard jobs and then they're like well you
keep talking about women like do you
hate
do you hate women and I'm just like
I am a woman
I don't hate women and then they're like
well you you say all women I'm like all
right all right feminists are you happy
and then and then it was like we hit so
many topics and they would just get mad
or matter I had a great attitude I was
happy the whole time they couldn't they
can't bring me down
and it's crazy it was like four against
me because there were some conservatives
on the panel but there were no real
conservatives no real red pillars like
it was like more people that are kind of
in the middle or me I'm like a Die Hard
foreign
that came up I didn't talk as much about
this as I wanted to but they're talking
about beauty standards and I'm like I'm
sorry
I'm sorry I've had hundreds of videos
made about me calling me ugly
if I don't let those get to you you
cannot make it an excuse that you saw
the Kardashians growing up and that made
you feel bad about yourself you you you
let people make you feel bad that is a
choice you can choose to let it get to
you or choose to just say you know
I'm a I'm a bad [ __ ] and there ain't
[ __ ] you can do to make me mad
that's a choice um it was actually
really oh my God
oh my God the guys this part of the
video
this part of the video is gonna get cut
it is absolutely going to get cut
oh but I wish they would leave it in oh
it was so funny this girl
I forgot I forgot her name off the top
of my head
she was so cool hold on
[Music]
um
I don't I don't want you guys to see how
messy my room is
um this girl this girl
oh god oh [ __ ] okay
um this girl named let me see
um what's her name what's her name
what's her name
uh oh Sydney Watson Sydney Watson and I
guess she's a big like YouTuber
um I I I'd recognized her I'd seen her
before and
she was on the panel with me and there's
this guy named Eli and I didn't know any
of this drama but I guess Eli I thought
this was an accusation but
I I guess he publicly put in his
Instagram he's giving drugs to minors
two miners
and
and I guess like Blair White made
there's all this conservative drama that
I've never heard of and but I guess
Blair White made a video about him that
he has like grape accusations and um
yeah and so we're talking about me too
and I think he said something about like
believing women or he she I don't know
and
she goes that's funny that you say that
with all the accusations that are out
against you
I didn't I was just sitting there like
she did not
she that this girl says it twice oh I
[ __ ] with her so hard I was like she
has no they're gonna cut it there's no
way they're gonna put that in there
but I swear to God it would be so good
yeah
but to me
it just rooted in my mind even further
that when you bring me I would say I'm
pretty far right
and you bring the really far left
that the left is nuts and you could
bring the most extreme conservative
you can bring Ben Shapiro in this [ __ ]
and we'll have a civil conversation
they also were getting on me they're
like Pearl with all her facts and you
know what the funniest thing is I'm
getting so good at this
I could just recite them off the top of
my head I was like I didn't even really
do research
before I came there
but I just knew it because I I argue and
debate so much
I'm trying to think of what else yeah
but it was so cool shout out to Vice
though Vice
I really like the staff there they're
really nice
um again don't know how they're gonna
edit I might hate them when it comes out
in January
but this video is literally us arguing
for like three hours straight another
thing I wish I said this I did it I
thought of it later but I said we were
talking about Planned Parenthood and I
was talking about how planned like they
they kept calling me white and I was
just like
and privileged and I kept saying yeah
okay I'm white and privileged
and
is what I'm saying untrue no because
when they
and then they kept saying oh you're
insecure and I'm just like
oh you people you people are crazy
anyways so they say you're white you're
privileged and then so I'm like it's
funny how all of y'all care about black
issues until we talk about one of the
number what should be one of the number
one black issues is that Planned
Parenthood is a Eugenics organization
started by a racist that referred to
black people as weeds and 80 of planned
parenthoods are in minority
neighborhoods
and then they're like well conservatives
use this as a talking point but Planned
Parenthood has a website that disavows
Margaret Sanger and I'm like so you have
a racist organization
that
but it's okay because they have a
website
I was like it's okay because
you have a web page dedicated to I
didn't say that but I swear to God I
wish I did and and
I'm thinking back I'm like
what does the website do and plus her
grandson was just working in it like not
too long ago and using the same language
when he was interviewed about the
overturning of Roe versus Wade I'm like
these
these people are nuts um
yeah but there was
I had a great time I knew my role I knew
they wanted a villain you you need a
villain I'm coming I'm ready
send me sign me up I was like I'll argue
with the lips and it was kind of
annoying because the conservatives that
were like on my side
I would say Sydney was the most
conservative one there
but there was like two others but they
were only kind of conservative and they
were cool as hell shout out to y'all but
like
so it was kind of like me versus the
whole panel in Sydney versus the whole
panel and it was just like then they
just kept being like you're white women
and then they're like
your and it was so funny they're like
you're the beauty standard I'm like I'm
the beauty standard shut up shut up all
these videos call me ugly three times
I'm like I'm like
me oh shout out to me I'm like you think
it sounds like you think I'm pretty
[ __ ] you
it's like they can't even they don't
know what to do with me because I'm just
I'm on a left field
I'm about to left field
um and it was funny then they're talking
about
ah
oh my gosh we covered so many topics we
covered abortion we covered beauty
standards we covered feminism
um they asked me what I thought feminism
was I was like it's equality when it
benefits us y'all don't care about
double standards when it comes to men
I'm like
they they get you care about my body my
choice but what about the men when they
get drafted Selective Service baby
oh oh now you don't want to you y'all
want to vote but you don't want to get
drafted
that's mad that's crazy that's crazy
oh my goodness and I'm like what about
women have the right not to be mothers
why don't men have the right not to be
fathers
let's talk about child support if he
doesn't pay child support he goes to
jail but if they have an abortion they
call it my choice
I also then they're trying to say
I forgot there's one point where they
said they're trying to say that
like I made some conclusion about
abortions that it's like an easy choice
or like it's hard for women I'm like if
it was so hard for women to get an
abortion then 40 of abortions wouldn't
be their second time
getting an abortion
and I'm like that's UK and U.S stats
I mean if they're that if it was that
bad of an experience they wouldn't do it
again
and and they don't track
they don't track the 60 to see which
ones you get them in the future because
how would you track that will you get
one in the future like they don't know
so
anyways um
I'm in New York today
um I'm here I leave today
I go to New Jersey I'm gonna be at eight
at the table tomorrow then I go to
I'm gonna collab with Donovan sharp
um I know y'all got mixed opinions about
him I don't care that's my boy he's been
here for me since the beginning that is
my boy
um in a normal way don't don't make that
weird
um then I go to Dallas
um some content creators in Dallas and I
are doing some videos uh roommates
and then after that I'm going to Ella
I'm going to be on Jessie Lee Peterson
and then 18th to 20th I'm going to Vegas
we're going to do it's complicated and
there's a girl from Tick Tock I think
I'm gonna collab with
um
but yeah anyways like the video on your
way out um I know this was all over the
place but I just had mad thoughts after
yesterday I'm almost done with my coffee
subscribe to the channel ring that
notification Bell and I'll talk to you
next time